ce qui est fascinant quand on observe
depuis un certain nombre d'années c'est
c'est notamment sa capacité de ce qu'on
appelle résilience on l'a vu avec les
attentes a en tout cas dans les pays qui
avaient un fort imaginaire touristique
auparavant on l'a vu avec les attentats
en france notamment donc j'allais dire
malheureusement je ne crois pas du tout
que si rien ne se passe en termes de
politiques publiques la pandémie à moins
qu'elles se poursuivent
arrête totalement enfin face repenser
l'industrie touristique où se penchait
sur d'autres modes de pratiques
évidemment que cet été il va y avoir des
pratiques qui vont être différentes
j'ai un collègue économiste frédéric
thomas qui a fait une enquête sur sur ce
que les gens veulent faire alors il ya
cette attente de tourisme différent plus
écologique
mais en fait il ya la première attente
c'est surtout pouvoir repartir comme
avant donc d'abord il ya la question de
l'ouverture des frontières
on peut partir ou pas est ce que c'est
on peut avoir une réservation qui risque
de ne pas être annulée est ce qu on
risque de se retrouver en quarantaine
c'est surtout ça les questions qui sont
posées donc on va avoir un été un peu
spécifique où finalement on va se tester
d'autres formes de pratiques et
notamment peut-être une répartition sur
le territoire français différentes
et puis d un tourisme on appelle
domestique intérieur les gens qui
parlent dans leur propre pays ou en tout
cas en europe mais ça veut pas dire que
tout ne va pas repartir comme avant avec
avec un certain nombre d'enjeux
écologiques puisque vous l'avez dit à
l'industrie notamment l'industrie
aérienne est une des plus grandes
industries polluantes s'il n'y a pas une
réflexion
donc il me semble que ce moment est un
moment assez particulier pour repenser
les politiques publiques du tourisme
parce qu'en fait sens en ce qui se passe
sans prise en compte de ça je pense que
tout va repartir comme avant parce
qu'aussi c'est ce qu'on voit de
l'expérience qu'on a dû des épisodes
précédents où le tourisme a été impacté
notamment par le terrorisme
[Musique]